[Music]
stalker
yes everybody turn it up here baby how
are you um
i thought i would just um
speak about um
why i'm a good therapist oh okay good
but he's shaking it up a little bit on
such a deep level
well the title of this video is you
listening on benjamin my motive is pure
to help others on the healing journey
you don't need
so she's over them totally
and it is because i have
had so much abuse in my life
that i can relate to people let me guess
it's narcissist women always complain
about narcissists
because i've been there i was abused as
a child
physically emotionally
who wasn't lady get over it mentally
sexually
i was incested by most incest and i've
never heard it used as a past tense verb
before i was beaten by my mother
um she was very much an authoritarian
and that is why i probably
this makes you a good therapist i was
told a man was my father that wasn't my
father i was told my
uncle that my my brother
and lucky for me i was because i dropped
that generational
bull crap i stopped with my daughter
no beatings no not even no yeah
your daughter has a very well-adjusted
mother who [ __ ] drives across the
country
to follow a guy who was on sullivan's
sons
yeah you're right yeah your daughter has
it set finally your daughter got
you broke you broke the chains yeah
that's right your daughter sure [ __ ]
dodged that generational bullet
[ __ ] look at opie's mom over here
[Laughter]
you know slap on the butt or face or
anything no hitting
was allowed
so i was also
as a teenager you should probably go
talk to somebody
further so you can talk to herself she's
a good therapist not youtube
wouldn't be the people i would talk to
about that incested
by my step second step i'm not going
back by the way i'm skipping forward but
i still held a job i was a functioning
addict
but oh wait addict to what hold on hold
on let me back up
let's go back a little someone's gotta
back up a little bit
but a little too far boyfriend
that i left to go into treatment
to get off of drugs what
kind of drugs
so i was a drug addict and i can relate
to that what kind of drugs
drugs because it's not weed because you
still smoke weed so what i'm gonna go
with opioids
all right probably because
she sounds like one of those people that
it's just there's something about it's
the thing i didn't like about
opioids is that they feel amazing but
they there's this slow drain
and even when you get off them you just
eventually like somebody looks like this
like it just sucks the [ __ ] soul out
of you
it sounds like oh in that department
i um shot up every day
there it is there it is there you have a
bell i know you have a sound board you
have a bell there for me mike uh
i i there we go thank you oh but it
wasn't set up on the thing no i heard it
it came through fine all right i
i would have went with okay that's good
that's good that's good
five years but i still held a job i was
a functioning addict but
it doesn't make it right or good but i
think it does make it hilarious
fast-tracked me on my spirituality
so it's not just mental illness drugs
probably did fry her brain
you know like long-term heroin use and
long-term methods and stuff like that
will
fry your brain permanently so um
i have that experience and then so i got
all that going for me
which is nice which is nice
and i never forget it i met the dalai
lama himself found benjamin
you say to me
went on to use my training and my wisdom
and everything i went back and
held group therapies and individual
um imagine this nut bag being like i'm
gonna help you
let's start with therapy and you're like
wait what i will i'll let her but only
if i could pair mcdonald's gift cards
i'll pay it forward i don't eat that
stuff uh sponsors for people
in n a and in
a a and i wasn't a drinker never
i never really was in you're boring i
love that she says
i was never a drinker good good man good
thing you're not doing the hard stuff
just stick that heroin
you should have drank you dumb [ __ ]
yeah i did drink but
not i don't know not like some people do
i was more into the
opiates and stuff and you know
there you go later i got pills from the
doctor that
luckily i didn't take them all but i had
morphine but you took most of them right
but you took most of them though right
oh you know also do you have the extras
michael buy them from
you yeah seriously they don't really i
mean i know they have an expiration date
but they really never go
just take twice the amount they just get
less potent so if you get
boxies and percocets and perkins
molly percocet mask off [ __ ] man
lady you name it i had it
so uh and then they were ready to put me
on suboxone
and i did not go for that because i was
on methadone and i know how hard it is
to quit methadone
oh you are [ __ ] a mess this one is
strong enough to get she's a mesodone
through that like i didn't i didn't hit
my mouth
with a junkie for a mom instead oh yeah
that's way better cool yeah i'm sure
your daughter grew up very very
in a very well balanced home so she
appreciates all the sacrifices you make
often i'm on the other side of it so i
can help people with these things
no thanks um i just
know how to connect thoughts i know what
i know when people are lying i know when
you know what i'm going to start doing
right so i'm going to start giving
people advice to like that the kind of
stuff they love hearing
is now when somebody goes like man i
really want to get off like opiates and
i just don't know how i'm going to be
the guy that goes hey man just start
working out
oh cool you feel great for those people
yes
nothing better than being a [ __ ] rock
bottom drunk or a cocaine addict
somebody being like yo man just start
working out
and they're like wearing their fitness
after you're like i'll [ __ ] kill you
yeah you know what's better than a
runner's high any drug
any high any height it's not that one
they justify what they're doing i
understand all that i've been there
so i am genuinely here to help people
and
somebody really needs to can we get like
valley or one of our guys to chop this
up into a commercial
that would be great really would make a
funny ass commercial like for
somebody does a voice over like make
this a better
better help yeah cat goddess queen bee
uh mental health solutions so i did
heroin you know and i would shoot them
just have a fun little upbeat jingle
yeah
oh god that would be great yeah i just
just cut this up into a commercial for
for a mental health specialist
say what he wants but i just came across
uh an email i sent to coddington
three days before i left to go just came
across it
weren't seeking out looking at it still
seething
and it's uh it's seeing what my mission
was what i
wanted to do what i had i wanted to add
to
barataria but my goal was to live
in his home
[Laughter]
that matter of factly she said i wanted
to live in it
what's the [ __ ] problem here i'm the
weird one
[Laughter]
i'm just the psychic with healing powers
oh my god
that wanted to live in a home with your
children kitty goes showed up who showed
up to your p.o box with no warning
what and and now i'm the [ __ ] oh i'm
the dick in this situation
wow oh gasps bite much oh jesus christ
what are you doing oh [ __ ]
you know what'd be great with this too
someone pointed it out making it a
millennium video
millennium i was a functioning addict
though and i'm just wanted to help
people my nanny
an au pair helping to raise the children
express their creativity i probably
could have helped
charlie to talk maybe molest them
i don't know it's all i know i'm legally
ill i don't know
daughter was reading at three
i know i could have pulled him out of
that hey cat am i funny
i have that kind of magic in me
i can do things like that that and why
can't you get your own life together is
what i don't get right wouldn't that be
step one yeah why are you in why are you
living in an extended stay suites right
now
yeah this is the whole point of like a
self-help guru
is that like when you see them you go
wow that looks like a dude it's really
got a [ __ ] to get
like i want to be like that person
oh this could also be a george ash
commercial good point
expected this woman doing self-help and
therapy
would be like me uploading uh workout
tips to youtube
again why would you like doing videos
where i'm like all right this is how to
do a proper squat but like with my body
actually now that i think about it that
would be a free i'm surprised nobody's
ever done that
that would be the funniest youtube video
uh
the funniest youtube channel ever would
be a fat guy it's totally out of shape
going
all right guys today we're going to show
you how to do uh barbell flies
uh i'll show you how to do the proper
form it's just this
fat piece of [ __ ] first you're going to
want to get your knees spread out now
make sure they're
going dude everyone will watch this
video especially if the dude did
everything properly yeah of course
that would be [ __ ] hilarious a lot of
people don't trust me and i don't blame
them i can understand protecting your
children but he didn't even give me a
chance he didn't even
talk give me 20 minutes to
say my you know whatever i had to say
to because that's where the video ends
because you ambushed him at the post
office lady
and i'm sure you were not i'm sure you
were
quite a sight to behold and i'm sure
everything you were saying and doing in
your body language everything about you
is probably extremely off-putting
you know owen's an [ __ ] but he was
absolutely at every right to be
terrified of course
dude you were stalking his post office
my kid when she was three she was
reading she was
she was installing drywall she could
play beethoven like no that's true
your kid's a loser and you're a loser
stop it i'll tell you what your kid was
doing your kid was watching his
watching her mother use heroin in the
[ __ ] kitchen
that's not [ __ ] pretend like your
kids got it made
okay so my wow so your daughter that's
pretty crazy she read it three she was
playing piano that's pretty impressive
what is she doing now well she works at
a wawa
i don't know but she's the night manager
oh so paid more than the day manager
that's not bad
good morning everyone this
cat here she's back or my morning view
oh no this is from my new home in my car
where i'm freezing and feel like i have
frostbite on my big
cars don't have heat unless you're
running them sucks
you see and now now the videos that
she's making is um
like uh jake the asshole's channel
uh this took a few months it's a lot of
like cooking terrible food
i don't know where she's at now where's
labrae state park
la brea yeah lebret look yeah yeah uh
i'm just
uh california california
uh bro no he's back in washington okay
she's back in washington